taunton in somerset the green fields of
south west england could this be fertile
ground for a liberal democrat fight back
there was a surprise big win here at the
local elections in an area that has
traditionally voted conservative
the lib dems for so long in the
wilderness now a party beginning to
shine back through but this leader left
wanting more you won this council in the
locals and you're hopeful that you could
win a by-election here as well we didn't
just win it we stormed it we got 46
percent of the vote the tories were
pushed down to 30 which is a lot more
than you normally get the liberal
democrats are taking on the tories in
their heartlands eastern walton where
we're taking on dominic raab wimbledon a
place like guilford you know there's a
lot of seats where we are coming for the
conservatives
space to do that in the south of england
as the conservatives look to nurture an
80-strong majority predominantly made
from gains up north there's forgotten
shires
in the south in the west of england
places that have potentially been
conservative that they feel like the
conservative party perhaps has moved its
attention to different parts of the
country and they've been forgotten is
that part of what's going on i've talked
about the blue wall seats after the chef
and amnesia victory
and there was a sort of metropolitan
blue wall that people were talking about
now there's a rural blue wall as we go
into those conservative heartlands they
feel the conservative party's taking
them for granted they feel that they're
focusing on elsewhere in the country and
forgotten other parts of the country
you've detoxified yourself actually you
became
a party of government in those coalition
years
uh you were no longer a protest party
you were no longer an alternative to the
conservatives you're back to being a
protest party
i think we're getting over our message
better as well go back to what i said
you are a protest party aren't you yeah
we're a community politics party you
accept that people vote as well for the
liberal democrats because they don't
like what they've got in government well
some may do
some here feeling that way
midterm government blues combined with
frustration over the economy breeding
uncertainty around any future election
what have you voted in the past always
always conservative right
and you might wait you might not this
time what was the cost of living or
other things well if i just think that
they haven't done a
particularly grand job so far people
just can't continue
with the way that things are are going
with the cost of everything you know
friends of mine that are sort of working
full time are unable to buy sort of
sanitary products and things like that
and that's and that's ridiculous well i
would be a conservative
okay
i wouldn't be able to vote for them now
really why not i just think they're
terrible at national scale i think
they've completely misunderstood what
ordinary people want and what they need
in terms of cost of living crisis i mean
look around people are really struggling
and no one's done anything for them it's
very blue around here but
uh i think even
true blues are probably getting fed up
with what's going on you know with just
with the lies and
you know it's not good it was in towns
like taunton the south west of england
that the lib dems found themselves
routed by the tories in 2015 losing all
10 parliamentary seats in this part of
the world in a general election that
brought the lib dems to near total
electoral obliteration
after years in the wilderness though the
yellow shoots are beginning to bloom in
these blue wall seats these lived um
tory battlegrounds in the south and west
of england and their leaders hoping that
a good result in the local elections in
this part of the world will translate
into bigger things
pounding the pavements thanking people
here for their support last month here
yeah we won 46 of the vote in future
months he'll be hoping that percentage
is replicated elsewhere if the lib dems
are to have any chance of pushing
through in true blues southern territory
beth rigby sky news taunton in somerset